ja und jetzt wollen wir den Blick noch
mal so ein bisschen weiten und darüber
sprechen wie sich dieser Stellungskrieg
im Osten der Ukraine entwickeln könnte
und welche Rolle die westliche
Militärhilfe spielen könnte und das
besprechen wir jetzt mit dem
Militärhistoriker Prof dr Sönke Neitzel
hallo Herr Neitzel schön dass Sie bei
uns sind
hallo
solltet ihr da draußen Fragen haben an
Herrn Neitzel oder eure Meinung zum
Thema mit uns teilen wollen dann tut das
gerne hier im YouTube oder Facebook Chat
oder per Mail an ZDF
heute-live@zdft.de
seit Monaten wird bachmut wirklich hart
umkämpft welche strategische Bedeutung
hat diese Stadt in ihren Augen
also wir müssen glaube ich uns
vergewärtigen dass die Ukraine in
bachmut eine relativ gute ausgebaute
Verteidigungsstellung haben sie haben da
die Möglichkeit seinen taktisch relativ
lange gegen die Russen zu kämpfen und
wenn sie backen aufgeben würden
ist die nächste Verteidigungslinie
hinterbach mit einem sehr schwierigen
sehr offenen Gelände also die Gründe
warum die Ukraine so daran festhalten
ist eben auch die Frage wenn wir machen
und aufgeben
das haben wir eben in den Beitrag auch
gehört ist dann möglicherweise das ganze
doch was geht dann verloren was kommt
danach in Städten wie bachmut kann man
den russenhof Verluste zufügen das haben
alle anderen Schlachten schon gezeigt
und man hat einfach aufgrund der
geographischen Lage in Bach und die
besten Möglichkeiten sich zu verteilen
und das ist ein Grund warum die Ukraine
so daran festhalten es wird jetzt auch
so ein bisschen was haben sie ja schon
angedeutet in ihrem Beitrag symbolische
Frage weil selenski war da
es wäre ein Schlag wie die Ukraine wenn
Sie das aufgeben müssen nur wir müssen
uns auch vergegenwärtigen wenn bachmut
fällt geht da kriegt natürlich in der
gleichen Intensität 10 km westlich
weiter also es ist einfach eine
Situation der die Ukraine unter großen
Druck ist und deswegen dann auch da kann
man sicherlich noch zu wie die
öffentlichen wichtigsten
ja sie haben es gerade schon
angesprochen Bewegung gibt es da gerade
relativ wenig können wir da gerade die
Entwicklung eines quasi militärischen
Pass beobachten und wo könnte das auf
Dauer dann hinführen und passend dazu
fragt auch einen User wann fängt man
endlich an zu verhandeln immer mehr
Waffen zu schicken ist keine Lösung
da fangen wir mal mit der User Frage an
also natürlich glaube ich dass hinter
den Kulissen versucht wird Möglichkeiten
auszuloten
Spielräume auszuloten für Verhandlungen
nur das passiert natürlich nicht im
offenen also der deutsche Botschafter in
Moskau von Geier natürlich jetzt nicht
im ZDF live erklären also gerade vor hat
aber das ist natürlich
Geheimnisse nicht betreiben und ich
hätte großes Vertrauen ins Auswärtige
Amt auch ins Auswärtige Amt anderer
Staaten dass sie nicht in der Nase
bohren sondern dass sie natürlich
versuchen Dinge auszuloten Dinge möglich
zu machen das Problem ist nur
das Kriege in der Regel eben nicht am
Verhandlungstisch entschieden werden
sondern auf dem Schlachtfeld und so
schrecklich das für uns Deutsche
erscheinen mag und solange beide Seiten
glauben sie haben militärisch noch eine
Option
wird der Krieg auf dem Schlachtfeld
weitergehen und
meines Erachtens natürlich gar nicht
genau sagen es ist jetzt gessing ist
Putin der Ansicht nach der Mobilisierung
im Herbst letzten Jahres steht ja auch
wesentlich breiteren Füßen militärisch
die russischen Streitkräfte haben sich
erheblich vermehrt und ich meine
argumentieren zu können das Putin glaubt
um längeren Hebel zu sein also gut dann
aber keinen Grund in Verhandlungen zu
gehen weil er glaubt
über die Zeit heraus
eine bessere ein besseres Platz zu haben
als die Ukraine und die Ukraine hofft
natürlich auch westliche Waffenlieferung
das sieht das auswirkt also diese
deutsche Haltung die aus der User
hervorgeht dieser Stimme kriegt möge
eigentlich Enden das ist sehr
verständlich aber ähm das ist meines
Erachtens nicht die Logik Putins und
logischerweise auch nicht die Ukraine
die natürlich sagt ja Enden natürlich
bald
aber wir wurden gerne dass die Russe
unser Land verlassen und wir haben sie
auf einem Beitrag gesehen momentan
kämpft man ums Überleben und da ist die
die Vorstellung ein Kompromiss zu
schließen gerade wenn wir die
Kriegsverbrechen vom Mut und so sehen
nicht wirklich sehr attraktiv
wir haben ja passend zu dem Thema auch
noch eine Meinung aus der Community und
zwar sagt Bora B auf Youtube selensky
hätte in Washington nicht über bachmut
sprechen dürfen das war ein großer
Fehler danach hat sich Putin entschieden
die Stadt dem Erdboden gleich zu machen
Thema militärische Unterstützung aus dem
Westen da haben wir ja jetzt sehr lange
drüber gesprochen berichtet jetzt ist ja
die Entscheidung für die Lieferung der
Kampfpanzer da können die jetzt gerade
in dieser Situation noch Veränderung
bringen oder kommen die dann auch so ein
bisschen zu spät weil es dauert ja so
noch vier ich meine eher acht Wochen bis
zur Auslieferung
ja also vor Ende März werden die
sicherlich nicht an der Front sein wie
sich diese kampfpanzerlieferung konkret
auswirken werden ja das können wir heute
eigentlich noch sehr schwer abschätzen
nicht über diesen Krieg vor allen Dingen
nichts wissen das müssen wir noch mal
ganz deutlich an der Stelle sagen wie
alle
diskutieren natürlich darum und man kann
in den Medien hier sehen wir alle
versuchen uns eine Meinung zu bilden wir
wissen die wir nicht jetzt sagen in
militärischer Funktionen sind über den
Krieg sehr wenig aber selbst die
Bundeswehr weiß über die Lage der
Ukraine sehr sehr wenig die Ukraine sehr
zurückhaltend
so damit ist diese Frage für mich schwer
zu beantworten aber ich fange jetzt mal
an das ein bisschen zu ordnen also
es wird gesprochen über die Lieferung
letztlich von knapp 100 Leopard 2
Panzern die Ukraine haben zu diesem
Zeitpunkt heute und jetzt in diesem
Moment etwa 6 bis 800 Panzer die sie
einsetzen Unterstützung ihrer Infanterie
wir haben bisher keine großen Panzer
Gefechte gesehen und die Frage ist wird
sich das ändern werden also diese
Leopard Panzer anders eingesetzt als die
ukrainischen Panzer etwa für eine
ukrainische Gegend das wissen wir nicht
das kann oder ukrainische Generalstaaten
beurteilen das ist hängt sehr davon ab
wie die Ukraine diese Panzer einsetzen
das ist von ganz vielen Faktoren
abhängig
ich also das ist ein offener Fragen ich
glaube nicht dass 90 Kampfpanzer diesen
diesem Krieg eine wesentliche Änderung
verpassen werden für eine große
Gegenoffensive sind meines Erachtens die
Ukrainer noch zu schwach
weil die großen mobil gemacht haben und
unter diesem Aspekt
ist das was sie eben sagen too late to
little vielleicht dann vielleicht
zutreffend weil im September letzten
Jahres als die Fronten Bewegung war als
die Ukraine gegen Offensive gestartet
haben hätten diese Panzer sicherlich
noch einen Unterschied machen können ob
sie das jetzt können
werden wir sehen es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Stärkung der ukrainischen
Verteidigungsfähigkeit aber ob sie
wirklich dazu beitragen können jetzt
bald den Krieg zu werden das müssen wir
abwarten und da würde ich zumindest mit
bleistiftan Fragezeichen
Richtung Moskau noch wichtiger als das
Meditieren
wir haben hier chronologisch quasi noch
eine Frage vor den Waffenlieferungen aus
der Community an sie und zwar vom
YouTube User der Zeitgeist der fragt
speziell an sie hernalse sehen Sie die
Gefahr eines Zusammenbruchs der
ukrainischen Verteidigung noch bevor die
neuen Lieferungen von Panzern und
Schützenpanzern ankommen
also ich würde mal Rätselraten mehr kann
ich leider auch nicht machen und sagen
nein das sehe ich nicht ich glaube schon
dass die Ukraine auf einem relativ
soliden Fundament steht und ähm wir
müssen es leider so sagen also die die
die Ukraine haben ja fast 900.000 Mann
mobilisiert so schlimm diese Kämpfe in
bachmund sind so schlimm das Sterben das
ist das wird der Ukraine meines
Erachtens nicht das Rücken sondern da
sind wir glaube ich schon in einer
längeren Zeitung bezahlen
das Problem ist dass der ukrainische
Generalstab extrem zurückhaltend mit der
Ausgabe von Informationen ist und zwar
auch an die NATO auch an die Bundeswehr
die wissen natürlich mehr als ich jetzt
aber insgesamt können wir ganz ganz
schwer einschätzen wie eigentlich
wirklich die Lage auf der ukrainischen
Seite ist ich der Westen hat es seine
Nachrichtendienste mehr Informationen
über die Russland über die Ukraine und
diese Frage
erreicht die Ukraine möglicherweise so
ein Break Even Point wo die ukrainische
Armee zusammenbricht ähm ist für uns
unglaublich schwer zu beantworten meine
Vermutung wäre dass die Ukraine nicht am
Ende ihre Möglichkeiten ist sie hat eine
sehr hohe Kampfmoral sie können ähm sehr
viel improvisieren sie haben Kampf
Erfahrung
gehabt und die Verluste sind noch nicht
so hoch dass die Ukraine jetzt dass sie
an Medien Zusammenhalt verlieren würde
und jetzt zusammenbrechen würde das noch
nicht aber die die Frage ist natürlich
schon irgendwann kommt letzter Punkt
wann dieser Punkt kommt können wir als
als Stocker sowieso nicht nicht
voraussehen aber natürlich kommt dieser
Punkt da würde auch irgendwann in
Russland kommen wann diese Punkte
erreicht sind ob die in einem halben
Jahr erreicht sind in zwei Jahren oder
wann auch immer können wir nicht
voraussehen und wir können eigentlich
nur von Woche zu Woche
beobachten was dort passiert und mein
Argument wäre muss man nicht zustimmen
um ein Argument wäre der besten sollte
sich ein bisschen sputen die Ukraine
sind unterstützen damit es den
ukrainische Staat auch in Zukunft
weiterhin noch gibt
ja passt vielleicht gerade ganz gut
jetzt ist ja für Freitag diese Woche
auch ein EU-Gipfeltreffen in Kiew
angesagt was sind denn die Erwartungen
wenn man auf dieses Treffen guckt sie
Lenski spricht ja zumindest mal er
erwartet Zitat Neuigkeiten
ja also natürlich ungeduldig und wir
haben ja gesehen als die Entscheidung
verkündet wurde Kampfhunde zu liefern
hat dann ein wenig ich glaube am
gleichen Tag sogar noch ähm Flugzeuge
und auch 35 und U-Boote gefordert also
natürlich in der Situation wir haben es
auch in dem Beitrag gehört wenn man
davon ist wenn man das Sterben sieht
erwartet die Ukraine hofft die Ukraine
vielleicht die bessere Formulierung auf
westliche Unterstützung auch noch mehr
westliche Unterstützung ich glaube dass
dieser Gipfel der EU Gipfel vor allen
Dingen ein politisches Signal ist also
Signal und das ist immer man vielleicht
auch eine Hoffnung damit ein Frieden zu
erreichen der Westen wird die Ukraine
weiter unterstützt dann wird sie so
unterstützen dass Putin mit
militärischen Mitteln der Ukraine sein
will nicht aufzwingen kann die Message
du wirst diesen Krieg du bist eine
kriegst den nicht erreichen wir stehen
hinter der Ukraine
und das ist glaube ich ein wichtiges
Signal da müssten auch entsprechende
Handlungen folgen das passiert ja im
Rahmen der Möglichkeiten jetzt mit dem
Panzerlieferungen und es wird
wahrscheinlich auch nicht bei den 94
bleiben
aber ich
könnte mal über die die Kampfflugzeuge
vielleicht sprechen aber ich glaube dass
die EU auch gut daran tut sozusagen
eine gewisse Vorsicht warten zu lassen
immer zu fragen was ist militärisch
wirklich notwendig was können wir
liefern wie können wir den Krieg auch
nicht weiter eskalieren
und das das selenski deine andere Logik
hat ist klar aber die westlichen Staaten
haben eben auch ihre eigene und wollen
natürlich auch nicht sich direkt an
diesem Krieg beteiligen und insofern
wird es wahrscheinlich dabei bleiben
dass er insgesamt enttäuscht ist und man
wird sehen was jetzt da ein Tier
verkündet wird also wirkliche
bahnbrechen Neuigkeiten kann ich mir
eigentlich nicht vorstellen
Thema Eskalation dazu gibt es auch eine
Frage aus der Community und zwar vom
YouTube User radevortex der fragt wie
weit sollen Waffenlieferungen gehen bis
zum Eintritt der NATO weil das wird
passieren jetzt hat ja
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck vor kurzer
Zeit gesagt es werden keine Kampfjets
geliefert was kann da jetzt noch
passieren wie sieht es aus mit weiteren
Waffenlieferungen im Bündnis
also die klaren roten Linien sind meines
Erachtens die die Entsendung von Truppen
denn mit der Entsendung von Soldaten
werden man Kriegsparteien
völkerrechtlich ich kann ich kann keine
Stimme in der NATO das fordert und ich
sehe auch keine politische Stimmen die
das fordert und das ist also glaube ich
es ist dann wirklich die rote Linie
alles andere ist würde ich mal englisch
sagen die also die Frage ist natürlich
die man stellen kann zurecht sind
und da würde ich ein bisschen Ordnung
ins Chaos bringen die Ukraine hat ja
eine Luftwaffe von etwa 150 Kampf
Flugzeugen und sie hat etwa 50 davon
verloren
und natürlich wird die Berlin westlichen
Staaten irgendwann diese Verlust
ersetzen müssen sonst gibt es keine
ukrainische Luftwaffe mehr und der
Luftkrieg ist vielleicht nicht
entscheidend eben doch eine nicht zu
vernachlässigende Rolle also wenn man
will dass die Ukraine diesen Krieg
überlebt dann muss sie irgendwie einen
Luftwaffe haben um sich zumindest zu
verteidigen zumindest eine kleine
das wird nach meiner
Wahrnehmung darauf hinauslaufen dass
Polen bis Slowakei mit 29 Jäger
irgendwann dann doch an die Ukraine
liefern und selbst die werden irgendwann
kaputt sein oder abgeschossen sein
und das ist dann wahrscheinlich der Fall
an dem westliche Staaten möglicherweise
F16 Jagdflugzeuge liefern aber immer
noch in dem Ziel sein diese relativ
kleinen Luft am Leben zu haben etwas
anderes ist es was er selenski gefordert
eigentlich eine völlig neue ukrainische
bauen die selber auch nach Russland
wirken kann und z.B auf die russischen
Flughäfen Angreifen von denen russische
Kampfflugzeuge aufsteigen und ähm Kiew
oder andere Städte mit Langstrecken
beschissen wenn man das will ist das
eine völlig andere Dimension und das
wäre dann wirklich eine Eskalation weil
dann muss die Ukraine in die Lage
versetzt werden ein Luft kriegt nach
Russland zu tragen und das kann sie
eigentlich nicht ohne aktive westliche
Hilfe also diese beiden Dinge würde ich
unterscheiden diese Lieferungen der mit
29 werden wahrscheinlich kommen um
überhaupt die Ukraine weiter in die Lage
zu versetzen in der Dimension Luft sich
weiter zu verteidigen
lassen Sie uns jetzt zum Schluss noch
mal einen Blick nach Russland werfen
morgen ist er an historisch bedeutsamer
Tag die Schlacht um das ehemalige
Stalingrad jetzt sich zum 80 Mal und der
russische Präsident Putin wird im
heutigen Wolgograd eine Rede halten was
erwartet man von dieser Rede
ja das Problem ist dass wir Putin nicht
in Kopf schauen können und dass wir
eigentlich mit vielen Voraussagen falsch
schlagen wir haben ja auch gedacht dass
am 9 mai also den Tag des Sieges über
das nationalsozialistische Deutschland
jetzt vielleicht immobilienmachung
verkündet wird und sie wurde am 9 mai so
nicht verkündet bisher waren eigentlich
die Voraussagen
für diesen historischen Jahrestag
eigentlich immer falsch und daher würde
ich erwarten dass er eine Rede in dem
üblichen Ductus hält dass er versucht
eine Parallele zu ziehen vom großen
Krieg des Zweiten Weltkrieges der
Verteidigung in das Deutsche Reich und
seine Verbündeten zu heute dass er
wieder versucht gegen die Nazis in kieft
die vermeintlichen Anführungsstrichen zu
wecken und das er versucht eine
parallele herzustellen
weil er weiß dass damals im Zweiten
Weltkrieg die Völker das Sowjetunion
vielleicht gar nicht so für den
Kommunismus oder die Regierung sondern
vor allen Dingen für ihre Dörfer für
ihre Heimat bekämpft haben und das ist
da eine unglaubliche eine unglaubliche
Motivation gab sich zu bewerten und
erfüllt glaube ich dass ihm die
Zustimmung auch in der long run einfach
wegbricht deswegen wird er immer wieder
versuchen mit die Geschichte als
Argument die Geschichte als Waffe zu
verwenden sehr viel mehr
Eskalation der Kriegsführung oder
gleichen also mehr als Worte kann ich
mir nicht vorstellen ich weiß es
natürlich nicht wir müssen uns alle
überraschen lassen aber ich würde das
dann Parallelen ziehen zusammen Auftritt
auf dem roten Platz am 9 also was
ähnliches würde ich da aber
ja wir sind gespannt auf diese Rede
morgen hernalzel danke dass sie sich
meinen und diesen Fragen aus der
Community angenommen haben danke schön